Dr. Cutters, I continue to appreciate all the support and receiving from your clinic.
I have been with S&T back on our phone appointment regarding my latest labs, which shall
show some of the two markers still elevated and some remaining stable, but others were
within dual range.
My glucose continues to be higher than optimal.
This person's glucose still wasn't even over 100.
Should I be changing anything I'm currently doing?
No, I think maybe getting another cheek swap every test something, is it might be a good idea?
On the other hand, I meant to ask about my current supplements I've heard on the Zoom calls,
and it's a good to switch up supplements as well as diet is another cheek swab warranted.
So that's a good question.
How often should we do cheek swaps?
So I'm doing really great.
One line of thought is, hey, I've been doing really great.
I'm in a state of remission.
I'm not really in the person just continuously.
They don't change anything.
They continue on their protocols.
That's one philosophy and it can work really well for some people.
Other philosophies out there is that even when you're doing great, sometimes it's good to
change protocols.
So I tend to favor that and do another cheek swab because typically when we test people,
even if they're in a state of remission, they've been doing great for a year.
We test people.
I change us.
Your body changes.
I take them off of things and change them onto something else because that's what test best forms.
Cancer's always constantly trying, it's changing and constantly trying to find pathways
better replication and you just kind of got it, you're better off staying ahead of it.
So getting another cheek swab is more, how often should a person do a cheek swab?
Well, certainly when they have changes in their body, let's say their symptoms change majorly
or something like that, they don't feel well.
If it's something like, hey, you know, in the old days, I guess you'd go to the doctor when I felt
this way, that's the time they get a cheek swab.
And then maybe every three to six months, it's good just to get another cheek swab.
Even if you're doing great, thermography is a good to do thermography.
Well, you should follow the schedule of the thermography, the last thermography.
So again, you would not follow the schedule if you had changes, you felt another lump or something
like that. But when you do thermography, at least through a medical clinic, they'll say,
they'll give you, you should do another thermography in six months or three months or nine months or
12 months, and you should just follow that schedule, unless there's changes.
These things that I intended to bring up, I'll be checking with labs again in January,
continue with regular detoxing, right?
Program's the PA I have been seeing for my thyroid medication is recommending that I do a cleanse.
Okay, so if you look at my detox course, you'll see that, you know, I don't really believe in
doing cleanses. You're constantly cleansing. You're constantly doing that. You're constantly supporting
detox pathways and such. You're doing coffee items. You are doing a cleanse. So I wouldn't think
that she thinks I have leaky gut. Well, certainly we could do some tests for leaky gut. That would be
the Syrex 2, 3, X and Syrex 4 to test for those things. Those are good things to test for.
Can you just assume that everybody has leaky gut? Well, yes and no, but yes, it would be good idea
to be checking for that. If you could afford to do some lab, it's always better to do the labs.
So maybe, you know, you have a lot of questions, maybe we should just chat again in schedule a time.
So let's chat with me again.